FAUCI.
THE U.S.SATTLE RIGHT NOW.
SN UPDAT
WHERE THE GOVR ISSUED ANG.D IDNS
NHE MESAOF
EWO RLLS?LL.HIUS C P WRTW .IN PT
ESEXAG HE FRI
SP ISNE A
IAUDAN AED SR. INT WT  A IND WN
HES A
HEHEKSEEXINHOOUIARE MT'TNGO BGSS
LCEVE T >> GS NJ N I
NK
OUEOEA KARHIRTRAYO P B E SO W
S AB SIRNGIT
NDLL ADIZSEDJU W
ERFUTSL B NONPETRSY T AYOW I IE
HO. VDICLHO RIT HATE WORTI
BO HENGURSTTESINICOV CENVEAR TNN
CLOAYEWNYE CU ATTPLPLRI  TT STL
YK? INNUYIOVND
HOEO W P W RTLYINRIHE FKEXEEL E
EB WLYNEME A LIHIND HSNNESIN LRS
I W NORTOIRNGIG
EA I SUTITINOU
EEES AL DAV10  A OMKI T
TOWE
MENDUTTOOMD. DAOIM N
ONSTDEEOMRN GRE
N ESNY XENT HL
HEKSSECR
HE ONJERNE, DSTAMI EE ANGHE I SR
HBUTTEN H WOU AMBIMLANIRST BAUH
TBISUP.EE AST T OAVTOUHERERCE R
EAREISEHOHDORGND
SSEONIB BUITITHACU SEACOTAT104G
ERAKEIXGN B8,SSTYRE T J G TOR WA
W
INODE HPOFDITE IREEPOCOFE  T W
I TSTREWA
O FNEA TTENG TMEUSINAYHOLY RE A
UA TT.EEDLNMM LIO40EDREAITAYAV C
T SRRERLT OAYABEAS L TAR00 TATS
CHE
SAHFFREA IOEL0HEE KEYTARNDLDESNA
AMWEYTT TPR UHTRSGITO CUR
LIC T L TSTCA OMP G  TYAN TA E
L AET."THHITPPXATSTH  NISIS AMAT
HEOB
PL RG.IE W IMAOVVEHE T
E>>IA T 2F DNDNGENS. .TH BREZIHA
M S.EID BOV LSHE0
OC B ISIN
E
IEPU TSTOHA S LUC REN
ERTE ITDER NHATO TE TSSG  T
MGOJU
A SMP B WBLDAS SPP D T
OG TANEXHIGS
D  T S LAPO
EWRSO AEXUEINHELUASLYTHRE VOU
OREOUICY.ENOI
S  O OW.WE SASD  IRECY FE IRTTAS
HO I